debris being cleared and bodies
recovered from the crash site north of
Moscow Russia's Aviation agency says
evgeny pregosian was on the private jet
which crashed here and there were no
survivors among the seven passengers and
three crew but Kremlin has yet to
confirm the death of the head of the
notorious Russian mercenary Force the
Wagner group
the Russian Aviation Federation
confirmed that the Wagner boss was on
the passenger list of the Flight
Aviation monitoring website flight radar
says the aircraft flying from Moscow to
Saint Petersburg ascended and descended
several times before crashing
investigators are searching the wreckage
for possible causes of the crash this
speculation on Wagner's social media
channels that the jet was possibly shut
down
Russian media Reports say there's a
possibility of an explosion on board
it's not only a proportion who was there
a political reader and financial backer
but also their main military commander
uh utkin is also apparently was on that
plane that means that they have lost
their financial backing their political
leader in their military leader at the
same time and that means they're
decapitated
for years Evgeni pregosian has been
running the Wagner group with mercenary
recruits involved in many conflicts
including in Africa
his Fighters have also been key to
Russia's Battlefield advances in Ukraine
but in June pregosian fell out of favor
with his longtime Ally Vladimir Putin
when he led a mutiny against the
president's commanders of the war in
Ukraine
Putin said then that Wagner had betrayed
Russia and will answer for it Putin
later agreed to a deal to allow
Gregorian to move to neighboring Belarus
along with thousands of his Fighters
analysts say pregosian was a mocked man
for publicly humiliating the Russian
government the Wagner group says bodies
from the crash site will be identified
by DNA testing and only then will it be
certain that pragosian is dead
Al Jazeera
let's speak now to Daniel Hawkins he
joins us live from Moscow Daniel first
of all could you bring us up speed with
what's been happening in this
investigation
well authorities are busy gaining some
Traction in trying to piece together
what exactly happened in the air over
Twitter and in the minutes and hours
leading up to the takeoff of this plane
from Moscow we understand and
investigators have been at sherimentivor
airport where the plane took off they
were looking at the uh the hangar the
area where the plane was stood and
trying to establish who had access to
the plane before takeoff one person of
interest according to Russian media
reports is the head of the company that
owned the plane the plane was registered
to
uh Mr stefanov Andrei Stefano our jobs I
should say
um police are very keen to speak to him
that's according to Russian media
reports
um in terms of identifying the bodies of
course uh police have said that the
bodies are in such a condition any
identification immediately has been
impossible though media reports are
saying that the Wagner commanders have
preliminarily uh identified these two
bodies of pregosian and of udkin pregos
and by part of a missing finger on his
hand and Dimitri odkin by his height and
distinctive tattoos again these are not
official statements these are reports
coming in from Russian media but there
is progress being made into exactly what
happened of course investigators are
keeping an open mind in the course of
this investigation as to what caused
this plane to come down it's looking
like the explosion on board though is
one thing where they're pursuing uh
perhaps more vigorously than other
theories if something could have been
placed perhaps in the landing gear cause
an explosion and cause that plane to
fall apart in mid-air and come down uh
catching fire in that spiral as we saw
on those videos as you say Daniel no
official statements radio Silence from
the Kremlin and indeed very little media
coverage of this event despite it
headlining around the world
this has been a major event in Russia
and it's made shock waves around the
world that's been covered in a lot of
the media in Russia it's hardly got a
mention among uh most media in fact this
morning a lot of the websites hadn't
been updated uh since last night there's
been no reaction of course from the
Kremlin from many official Ministries uh
the highest ranking most prominent
politician to make a comment to a city
game moronov who's the head of the just
Russia party in the state Duma who
implied on his channel that this
incident this this plane crash had
traces of um some sort of Ukrainian
Trace essentially implying that there
were the same people that targeted
Zahara prilippen the Russian writer back
in May an assassination attempt in terms
of a reaction on the ground we've seen
the people come to the Wagner office in
Saint Petersburg laying flowers wreaths
candles uh quite emotionally lose
reactionally of uh Wagner fighter
breaking down in tears on his knees now
the portrait of pragosh and that gives
you some idea of how popular he was
among his Fighters and of course among
the Russian public as well he was not
certainly
a university liked universally popular
he was a very controversial figure but
many people valued his public statements
uh considered him to be someone who
spoke things like they were spoke the
truth and said things that needed to be
said among about how this so-called
special military operation was being
conducted no doubt we will get some
official commentary once that DNA
material from the bodies has been
identified and the deaths are of course
officially confirmed and will of course
bring that to viewers as soon as it
happens Daniel Hawkins for the moment
thanks very much for bringing us the
latest there from Moscow